[Music]
what's up Marvin lights I'm Ryan and I'm
Jamie and this is a super cool ultra
awesome mega sized trivia challenge our
partners at upper deck have these
amazing Marvel Studios Black Panther
trading card yes and they're dope we've
been looking at them and we figured what
better way to test our knowledge of
Black Panther than with these cards in a
trivia challenge contest oh there is no
better way I am ready for this Ryan are
you ready super into it let's do this I
was born ready okay so the the set for
upper decks Marvel Studios Black Panther
cards comes with a ton of cool cards
some really rare ones some chase ones
but it also comes with these awesome
stills from these are the base cards for
the set so you want to collect all your
packs get as many as you can so you can
get the full set and I figured a cool
way to show them off would be to do a
little trivia I'm going to put a cart to
my head like this okay I need some
descriptions of the characters I'll try
to name them I will do as many as we can
in 60 seconds all right this is what a
member of the wakandan royal family it
is not the main character sharee
no Queen remonda there you go okay this
is more than one character but now it's
two members of the royal family
sharee to chawla yep okay this is
actually the first time we see one of
the closest confidants of the royal
family and I'll just say her
relationship with T'Challa is
complicated Nakia yep
ooh my brain 'i'm card ooh a vibranium
is hard oh it's a little warm in here
but yeah this is a someone who was
wakandan at some point and come on ger
there you go
okay this is something you do not want
to mess with a fierce warrior all right
I got four that's pretty good pretty
good for in sixty Seconds I can't
complain okay
all right you ready for this we shuffle
these because I saw the first one okay
good that's fair I appreciate it okay
didn't don't know what this one is go
all right so this is one of the
antagonists of the film he has a an arm
his arm has been changed because of his
film
it's the Winter Soldier aka white wolf
nope
villainous ish character claw claw and
he's talking to a government member
who's Everett Ross correct okay okay
I've got three characters on here two of
them are there's a complicated
relationship going on okay Nikki and
T'Challa yep and then I believe the
other one is a member of the royal
family
Cherie yes all right so here you've got
the the ceremony that where it's child
becomes Black Panther he and his
father's advisor well I already told you
one of them so it's a Charla and Zuri
correct okay okay so here we see that
complicated relationship again Oh how
made you get I got three okay oh okay
okay that is one more than three yes and
it means I get this sweet vibranium card
oh yeah is terrific and it's awesome and
it's heavy and it's one of many cool
chase and variant cards that come in
this set it is just the dopest look at
all of these I'm looking at these
original art sketch cards right here
those are dope I really like we've got
the King's mantle cards over here which
actually have pieces of screen and
production used costumes in the cards
which is those are neat
there are even photochromic reactive
cards that change color and sunlight so
rare we didn't even get any and all the
packs that we open hopefully you guys
get some when you go to your local store
pick up some packs or go to upper deck
keep a calm because that's where you're
gonna go for all of this yeah not only
all of this but if you go to upper deck
be packed calm get exclusive cards you
could only get online you can review
your entire digital collection you can
do a little trading
go to upperdeck EPAct comm for the
exclusive online only stuff I love it
alright we're gonna wrap up this video
we're gonna open up some more packs here
and I'm Ryan and I'm Jamie
this is Marvel your universe
[Music]